- So your mom was musical, right?
- My mom actually moved to
California chasing my father
and she came with a guitar.
- [Kelly] And a dream.
- And a dream.
Yeah, she always wanted to sing.
She made a little 45
when she first got here.
That was a long time ago children.
- [Kelly] Is that her?
- Oh yeah, that's my mother's singing.
- [Kelly] Look at this character.
I love her and I want that hat.
- That's my mother trying
to sing "Old Town Road."
(kelly and audience laughing)
I don't know if the road is old or new
but I don't wanna be on it.
- Did she sing like that
all the time, just randomly?
- Well, you know what ends up happening,
in my house from Mother's Day,
the kids always do a talent show for me
because I perform for the world.
I'm like, "Y'all get up there
and do something for me."
- I love that.
- I love that too.
(audience applause)
- I make them do it.
- With a smile, "I make them do it."
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- And my mother never wants to be left out
so sometimes she'll get in on the act.
- She's a grab the mic mama.
Oh, I love that kind of mom.
- Very much.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
This is where the
personality came, okay, okay.